Мене, безумовно, здивувало, що в Фінляндію запит на 14-15 тисяч людей.
Можете назвати умови, які мають виконати бажаючі виїхати за кордон на роботу?
Ці умови на сьогодні обмежені лише коронавірусом.
Ми не запитуємо, чим збираються займатися люди, не з’ясовуємо скільки їм платять.
Такого зараз немає, що когось не пустили?
Ми не Радянський союз. Залізна завіса давно заржавіла і впала.
Яким є план "Б" щодо Донбасу?
Є і план "С". Треба дочекатися, наскільки цей план "Б" буде ефективним.
Через епідемію кооронавірусу до України повернулися тисячі українців,
які працювали в ЄС.
Наразі вони чекають, коли знов можна повернутися до роботи.
Коли в них з’явиться така можливість?
Дякую, це дійсно питання багатьох турбує. Ми отримуємо багато звернень,
і тут є певні непорозуміння.
Дехто нам, до речі, свої резюме надсилає, знаючи, що офіс займається координацією,
і просить,  чи можемо ми  його прилаштувати за кордоном.
Саме тому, хотіли  б сказати, що питання відновлення праці наших людей,
які звикли  працювати за кордоном, залежить в першу чергу від роботодавців
в тих країнах, де вони звикли працювати.
Уряд України не обмежує.
Ми лише намагаємося придати цьому руху  якусь координацію.
Все більше і більше рейсів відновлюється і авіаційні,
і ми зараз працюємо над автомобільними, і залізничними рейсами.
З якими країнами є домовленості на найближчий час про спецрейси?
Переважно ми говоримо з нашими партнерами з ЄС.
Відлетіли рейси на Лондон, відлетіли рейси на Гельсінкі, відлетіли рейси до Німеччини.
Ми говорили не тільки з країнами ЄС.
Наприклад, є домовленість про певну кількість робітників до Ізраїлю.
Про яку кількість людей взагалі йдеться?
На Австрію, наприклад, планується 802 людини точно. Деякі країни не мають такої точної цифри.
Ми говоримо про Фінляндію. Від 12 до 15 тисяч за весь цей період до серпня.
В Німеччині важко сказати через ії федеральний устрій.
Кожна федеральна земля запрошує по-своєму.
В Чехії наших працівників – це найбільша етнічна група, яка перебуває там.
Тобто, ми уявляємо, про які цифри ми говоримо.
Це від сотень до десятки тисяч людей.
Як відбувається наразі дипломатична комунікація по цьому питанню?
До України звертаються уряди країн? Чи-то звертаються окремі роботодавці?
Зараз, враховуючи  те, що ми говоримо більше про аграрні роботи, які мають певний календар…
От ця складність, яка примушує уряди звертатися до нас,
і кожна країна намагається це вирішити прямо зараз.
Звичайні роботодавці звертаються до своїх урядів.
Те саме, що робить Україна, те саме роблять уряди інших країн.
Тому що деякі уряди просто закривають не для громадян, наприклад, ЄС.
Таке рішення загальне було прийнято в Німеччині.
Тобто, кожний такий приїзд організованої групи – це виняток.
І ми, в принципі, уряди нам надсилають навіть переліки людей, про кого йдеться мова.
Ми не перевіряємо контрактів,
ми не допомагаємо або не заважаємо ці контракти укладати.
Ми не запитуємо, чим збираються займатися люди, не з’ясовуємо скільки їм платять.
Я правильно зрозуміла, що людина не може вилетіти з України, якщо її немає в списку?
Станом на сьогодні, як це відбувається…
Немає такого переліку, що сидіть прикордонник і по переліку  перевіряє. Ні.
Це не радянський підхід.
Дозвіл дається на рейс конкретний. Авіаційні перевізники продають квитки.
До речі, хотів би відзначити,
що дехто помиляється, думаючи, що ми говоримо лише про МАУ. Ні.
Навіть рейси, які нещодавно відлітали, зокрема, до Австрії рейс…
Він виконувався латвійськими авіалініями по замовленню австрійських роботодавців.
Будь-який чартерний рейс, який ми дозволяємо вилетіти, як країна, в незалежності
від того, хто його виконує.
Звичайний цивілізований процес бізнес-перельоту...
Кожний такий чартерний рейс, просто узгоджується між урядами.
Ми не Радянський союз. Залізна завіса давно заржавіла і впала. Ми не плануємо цього робити.
Ті, хто купив квітки, придбали на конкретний рейс, вилітає.
Всі, хто на ньому був з квитками, всі вилітають.
МАУ - єдина авіакомпанія, яка виконує ці рейси?
В більшості виконує перевезення, коли це з України, то МАУ.
Але так саме виконує Sky Up, наприклад, дуже часто з українських авіаліній.
А також всі інші авіалінії, які домовляються.
Для чартера, в принципі, не так важливо національність походження літака або екіпажу.
Частіше просто проблема,
хто знайшов дешевший переліт для того, щоб зменшити витрати.
Можете назвати умови, які мають виконати бажаючі виїхати за кордон на роботу?
Ці умови на сьогодні обмежені лише коронавірусом.
Ми висуваємо пару дуже простих умов.
Перше умова - це організований виїзд людей на період більше трьох місяців.
Щоб це дійсно було організоване працевлаштування,
щоб ця людина, яка виїхала, не повернулася на наступний день,
не перетворюючи наш кордон в постійний рух  людей.
Дехто  з них заражений вірусом і він підхоплює… І ви бачити, що відбувається.
Не таємниця велика, що більше уражені області, які знаходяться біля західного кордону.
Також є умова - обов’язкове медичне страхування.
Слава Богові, в ЄС це питання вирішене.
Це більше цивілізоване працевлаштування, ніж, наприклад, в РФ.
Що, в принципі, нам більше подобається, що наші громадяни,
перебуваючи за кордоном, захищені.
Чи є якісь запит, який Вас особисто здивував? На робітників з України…
Мене, безумовно, здивувало, що в Фінляндію запит на 14-15 тисяч людей.
І є списки,  які подаються фінськими агропромисловими компаніями,
і навіть маленькими фермерами.
Мені розповідав міністр закордонних справ Фінляндії і посол Фінляндії про те,
що деякі з фермерів так давно наймають регулярно,
що ці люди просто приїжджають, в них є ключи від амбарів,
де стоїть сільськогосподарча техніка, якою вони і керують самі.
Власник навіть не знає. Вони готують поля, вони фактично працюють у взаємодії…
Це не зовсім робітники, це, скажімо, партнери.
От, я не уявляв, наскільки багато людей - українців з готовністю працювати,
з силою і знаннями, на жаль, працюють за межами України. Це мене здивувало.
Як було вирішене питання на таку кількість людей? Скільки це рейсів?
Якщо суто математично підійти до того, щоб забезпечити переліт до Гельсінкі
і через 4 місяці назад 14-15-ти тисяч людей,
Рейсів ми рахуємо не менше двухсот.
Але ми говоримо не лише про літаки, ми говоримо і про автомобільні перевезення.
Автобусні скоріше.
Ми зустрілися з представниками цієї галузі, які незадоволені тим, що їх бізнес страждає.
Ми зараз намагаємося зрозуміти, як зробити так організовано,
як ми до цього часу змогли зробити з авіаперевізниками.
Крім автоперевізників - автобусних, вочевидь, буде підключено і залізничне сполучення.
Ми, як раз зараз, уряд відкрив сполучення залізничне.
Поки небагато цих пунктів пропуску. Але перші поїзди вже поїдуть.
На Перемишль, наприклад, будуть їхати потягами.
Скільки українців вже перевезли за кордон за трудовими контрактами?
Ми, дійсно, уявляємо, яка кількість перетнула  українців.
Але, насправді, не всі вони дочекалися от цих домовленостей і координації,
дехто з них виїжджає автобусом, пішки переходить,
щоб далі сісти на найближчий рейс з країн, які відкриті, і рухатися далі.
Якщо це на Фінляндію 14-15 000, в залежності від потреб їхніх фермерів,
то ми приблизно уявляємо цю цифру.
Трохи складніше з іншими партнерами, які не так чітко централізовано організовані,
але ми працюємо, усвідомлюємо ці цифри.
Уряд України висуває вимоги іноземним роботодавцям
щодо офіційного працевлаштування та медичного страхування робітників з України.
З чим це пов’язані ось такі вимоги влади України?
Враховуючи епідемію, ми би хотіли бути впевненими,
що ці люди отримують медичне страхування і воно дійсне…
Коли уряд з урядом говорить, то наші вимоги чіткі,
що це має бути страхування, яке дозволить цієї людині лікуватися.
А коли це робиться стихійно, я не впевнений, наскільки повно
покривається перебування людини за кордоном.
Чи не образливо це для України, що громадяни України
під час сезонних робіт їдуть допомагати фермерам в Європі, а ні своїм?
Я вважаю, що справедливо використано Вами слово "образливо".
Дійсно для мене, як для члена українського уряду, це образливо,
що наші люди вимушені шукати так далеко  роботу і заробіток,
що ми не змогли створити усі умови для того,
щоб ці люди залишилися зі своїми родинами і змогли
хоча б таку саме приблизну суму заробити.
Ми стараємся зі свого боку зробити, як уряд, ми намагаємося зацікавити цих людей,
які є активними, які є рухомими, які звикли до нових бізнесів,
до його ведення, з яким воно познайомилися за кордоном, започаткувати свій бізнес тут.
Є, наприклад, програма кредитування 5-7-9,
де під 5-7-9% дають гроші для започаткування бізнесу.
Але навіть ця програма пройшла через певну модернізацію,
і в деяких випадках ці кредити зведені урядом до нуля.
В першу чергу, бізнесмени можуть використати на ці невідкладені витрати,
які вони понесли у зв’язку з коронавірусом,
можуть навіть доплатити за оренду, яка зараз затягнулася.
Ми намагаємося перенести кредитування, зробити певні канікули.
В деяких випадках, дійсно, розмова ведеться, наприклад, як в програмі "Нові гроші"
про мінімальні кредити,
який люди можуть собі дозволити взяти і започаткувати бізнес.
Не знаю, придбати невеличку пекарню,
спробувати це зробити, як тільки буде можливість відкриватися,
і вона вже відкривається…
Врятувати той бізнес, який заборгував за послуги комунальні.
Чи є у вас особисто прогноз, коли відновиться міжнародне пасажирське авіасполучення?
Ви бачили цей 5-ти покроковий сценарій виходу з кризи.
І, дійсно, відновлення
повноцінного транспортного сполучення заходиться в самому кінці.
В силу певних обставин медичних суто.
Якщо ми будемо бачити, що картина позитивна, ми будемо перескакувати певні етапи
і пересувати найближче до сьогоднішнього дня відновлення транспорту.
На якому етапі адаптація українського  законодавства до угоди про Асоціацію з ЄС?
Зараз просто дуже вдалий момент, тому що
як раз підійшов історичний термін, коли ми можемо переглянути умови.
І на перегляд цих умов чекають наші виробники,
тому що більшість тих квот, які є, які поставлені, вони вже не влаштовують нас.
Ми перейшли етап перших контактів з ЄС в рамках угоди про  безтарифну торгівлю.
Я сподіваюся, що ми переглянемо. Крім того, є ще інші напрямки, над якими ми працюємо.
Наприклад, цифровий ринок, взаємодія в митних справах, юстиції, безпеці і обороні.
Ці питання, вони всі просуваються одночасно. Деякі - більше прогрес. Деякі - прогрес потрібен.
Наприклад, більше зацікавило б людей як-то зняття роумінгових обмежень.
Це те, над чим ми працюємо. Або "промисловий бевіз".
Щоб наші товари, які поставляють на ринки, не повинні були проходити через сертифікацію.
Тобто, нам би довіряли, що ті товари, які сертифіковані в Україні,
так само легко наступного дня потрапляють і в компанії європейські.
Чи є ризики невиконання Угоди?
Ризику невиконання Угоди немає. Є ризик того, що ми не зможемо досягти того, що ми хочемо.
Тобто, в нас амбіцій набагато більше, ніж реальність. Це єдиний ризик, який я бачу.
Яким є план "Б" щодо Донбасу?
Як планується визначити неможливість виконання "Мінської угоди"?
Ця розмова не сьогоднішня.
Ви пам’ятаєте, що ми починали з самого початку, коли президент Зеленський прийшов до влади,
наскільки довго можна йти тим самим шляхом, яким йшли
президент Порошенко і вся команда, яка працювала з ним.
Ми говорили про те, що український народ втомився від багаторічної війни,
ми втомилися втрачати солдат своїх і сама ситуація,
яка не вирішувалася, рано чи пізно має бути розв’язана.
План "Б" був в тому, що "мінські домовленості", які були записані,
в принципі, мали б закінчитися за один рік,
вони були продовжені по узгодженню з нашими партнерами.
І тоді президент Зеленський сказав, що до кінця року ми маємо побачити прогрес.
І цей привід був пов’язаний з зустріччю лідерів у Франції. Зустріч дійсно відбулася.
На жаль, прогрес був доволі обмежений і в більшості він був в обміні полоненими.
Всі інші пункти не були виконані, починаючи з безпекового.
Ми ще раз спробували так, як лідери домовилися, зустрітися ще раз
місяців через чотири приблизно - в квітні.
Коронавірус вніс серйозні радикальні зміни.
Ми тепер маємо зрозуміти, коли відбудеться, наприклад, зустріч
в форматі лідерів і коли можна досягти прогресу.
Знов таки, я чую, що говорять представники Адміністрації - Офісу президента про те,
що це можливо підрахувати десь до кінця цього року.
В будь-якому випадку, існує потреба визначити для себе серйозно,
коли нарешті ми зрозуміємо, як Україна, що йти шляхом
тим, яким ми йдемо останні 5 років, безрезультатно, неефективно.
Чому наразі це мають підтримати учасники нормандського процесу?
Чудове запитання. Напевно, тому що втомилися всі так само, як і ми.
Але ми страждаємо, наші люди гинуть.
Ті зусилля міжнародної спільноти, зокрема, санкції, вони теж втомлюють.
Постає питання кожні півроку про їх відновлення, їх ефективність.
І саме тому Україна заговорила про план "Б". Але є і план "С".
Тобто, умовно кажучи, план "Б" має передбачати, якщо Мінськ
в тому стані, який він існує, не працює,
до нього треба напевно додати щось, не відкидаючи загал.
Наприклад, це може бути запровадження миротворчої місії.
Про це говорила, як і українська сторона… Президент Порошенко перший порушив.
Так пізніше і російська сторона. Різні формати, але це обговорювалося.
Незважаючи на закиди, що це "поза Мінськом", "це вб’є Мінськ".
Нічого подібного. Обидві сторони пропонували  певні різні варіанти.
Цей план умовно міг би бути планом "Б". Наскільки за цим планом "Б" є план "С"…
Ну, напевно, треба дочекатися, наскільки цей план "Б" буде ефективним і рухатися поступово.
І яким є план "С" щодо Донбасу?
План "С" міг би бути наступним. Наприклад, ми далеко зайшли в майбутнє, придумуючи.
Але, як варіант, якщо Росія блокує рішення Ради безпеки ООН,
керуючись своїми можливостями члена Ради безпеки ООН,
блокуючи це рішення, вочевидь, план "Б" не спрацює.
Тоді треба зрозуміти, чи взагалі "Мінськ" є якийсь шанс його виконати?
Чи це перетвориться в ту історію, яка наприклад між Азербайджаном і Вірменією
відбувається останні 30 років.
Хочу нагадати, що вона, на жаль, теж називається "Мінський процес".
Дуже дякую.